اصدرت الامم المتحده عام
1947 قرارا يقضي بتقسيم فلسطين الى دولتين
عربيه ويهوديه منحت اسرائيل على اثره
78% من الاراضي الفلسطينيه و 22% فقط
ابقيت لفلسطين وتشمل الضفه الغربيه وغزه
والقدس في حرب يونيو عام
1967 التي دارت رحاها بين دول عربيه
واسرائيل
استولت الاخيره على الضفه الغربيه وغزه
بالاضافه الى ثلثي هضبه الجولان في سوريا
وشبه جزيره سيناء في مصر في العام نفسه
اصدر مجلس الامن الدولي القرار
242 الذي ينص على انسحاب اسرائيل من
الاراضي التي احتلتها ويسمح للفلسطينيين
باقامه دوله مستقله في عام
1944 اصدرت الامم المتحده قرارا جديدا
بشان التسويه السلميه لقضيه ف فلسطين دع
الى قيام دولتي اسرائيل وفلسطين جنبا الى
جنب دوله اسرائيل تشمل رقعه جغرافيه تتمثل
في كل الاراضي الفلسطينيه باستثناء الضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه والاخرى دوله فلسطين
تضم الضفه الغربيه والقدس الشرقيه وغزه
وما يربطها عام
1988 اعلن الزعيم الراحل ياسر عرفات
استقلال فلسطين وتحدث حينها لاول مره عن
دولتين لشعبين في عام
1993 وقعت اتفاقيه اوسلو التي توافق فيها
الطرفان على انشاء دوله فلسطين وكانت
الاتفاقيه املا لوضع فكره حل الدولتين على
الطريق الصحيح لاول مره خلال اجتماع منتدى
الاتحاد من اجل المتوسط في اسبانيا اعلنت
دول عربيه والاتحاد الاوروبي توافقها على
اهميه حل الدولتين لانهاء النزاع
الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني
ه